bien madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur général mes chers
collègues nous recevons ce matin madame
Sandrine Duchesne que j'envisage de
nommer au Conseil des finances publiques
afin de succéder à monsieur Éric Hyères
dont le mandat de 5 ans non renouvelable
vient à expiration ce mois de mars
monsieur Heyer avait été nommé par mon
prédécesseur Vincent et blé et dans le
cadre de cette audition publique je veux
en préambule le remercier de la manière
dont il a exercé son mandat dans un
contexte particulièrement intense pour
le conseil il faut le noter
marqué par la succession des textes
financiers et des avis remis pendant la
crise sanitaire économique énergétique
il est également intervenu à plusieurs
reprises devant notre commission
n'y voyez pas mais enfin quand même bon
devant notre commission pour apporter un
éclairage précieux à nos travaux
je vous remercie également madame
Duchêne votre présence parmi nous ce
matin à 8h30
et je m'en excuse auprès des auprès des
collègues nous avons été nous sommes
tenus par le calendrier et donc une
obligation de nomination aujourd'hui au
terme des dispositions de l'article 1er
de la loi du 6 décembre 2021 portant
diverses dispositions relatives au
Conseil des finances publiques et à
l'information du Parlement sur les
finances publiques votre nomination ne
peut en effet intervenir qu'après une
audition publique et conjointe de nos
commissions des finances et des affaires
sociales cette audition ne donne pas
lieu à un vote comme vous le savez le
Haut Conseil des finances publiques
est un organisme indépendant chargé
d'apprécier le réalisme des prévisions
macroéconomiques du gouvernement et de
se prononcer sur la cohérence de la
trajectoire budgétaire gouvernementale
avec les objectifs pluriannuels de
finances publiques et les engagements
européens de la France
composé de 11 membres dont deux sont
nommés respectivement par le président
du Sénat et par le président de la
commission des finances du Sénat en
raison de leur compétences dans le
domaine des prévisions macroéconomiques
et des finances publiques il est placé
auprès de la Cour des comptes et présidé
par le Premier Président de cette
dernière je vous propose donc de
commencer cette audition par un exposé
liminaire relativement concis puisque
nous disposons au total d'une heure pour
cette audition exposée pour lequel vous
pourrez nous exposer votre parcours et
votre conception du rôle du rôle du Haut
Conseil des finances publiques
mais avant que vous vous exprimiez je
cède la parole à Madame Catherine
Desroches présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales
merci mes chers collègues bonjour et et
merci monsieur le Président Renan mais
vous avez déjà dit l'essentiel donc
j'indiquerai simplement que la
commission des affaires sociales est
toujours très attentive aux avis rendus
par le par le Conseil des finances
publiques au moment de l'examen du pfss
et plus récemment encore lors de
l'examen du
plfs
oui c'est ça qui a porté la réforme des
retraites et d'ailleurs à cette occasion
le Conseil des finances publiques nous
avait indiqué le peu d'informations dont
il disposait pour étayer ce navire je
souhaite donc dans votre propos
liminaire vous puissiez nous nous
préciser votre familiarité avec les
finances sociales et le cas échéant le
regard que vous portez sur ce sous
secteur des finances publiques et je
vous remercie
merci Madame
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs mesdames et messieurs je
voudrais d'abord vous remercier monsieur
le Président pour votre soutien à ma
candidature à exercer ce mandat de 5 ans
au Conseil des finances publiques et
puisque vous m'y invitez je vais revenir
brièvement sur mon parcours et surtout
sur mes motivations à exercer ce mandat
alors sur mon parcours j'ai une
formation de statisticienne économiste
corps des administrateurs de l'Insee
dans lequel je suis rentré en 1993 et
pendant 20 ans entre 1995 et 2015 j'ai
exécé des fonctions opérationnelles en
matière de prévision économique et
financière au sein du ministère des
Finances à Bercy
en clair les finances publiques
au sens large je suis tombée dedans en
2002 à l'occasion d'un changement de
poste comme c'est souvent le cas à Bercy
au retour d'un congé maternité mon
deuxième et à l'automne 2002
rappelez-vous c'était le moment où il
devenait de plus en plus probable que le
seuil de 3% de Maastricht serait
franchie pour l'année 2002 et au passage
d'ailleurs ça n'a pas été le seul
critère qui a été dépassé puisque
le critère de dette à également été
franchi cette année là donc c'est vous
dire que je suis tombée dans ce chaudron
bouillonnant en 2002 et ça a été une
expérience vraiment très très
intéressante plus que cela et en fait ce
ben là je ne l'ai jamais vraiment quitté
en Suisse puisque j'ai exercé
à différentes fonctions au ministère des
Finances et ailleurs
au finances publiques mais aussi à un
moment sur les trajectoires de finances
sociales puisque j'étais en charge du
bureau santé compte sociaux donc j'ai eu
certaines sensibilité à ces sujets
et puis à d'autres fonctions y compris
auprès du président de la République
François Hollande entre 2012 et 2013
puis retour dans ma maison la direction
du Trésor en tant que directrice
générale adjointe et là j'ai eu le
privilège de d'être auditionné par le
Conseil des finances publiques qui
venaient juste à l'époque d'être créé
donc
ce parcours là je pense que c'est
important de souligner que c'est un
métier un métier très spécifique mais ça
éteint
parce que il combine à la fois de la
technique de prévision économique et
financière
l'analyse économique surtout des
finances publiques je pense que c'est le
plus intéressant c'est à dire donner à
voir le sous-jacent des finances
publiques au-delà des chiffres faciaux
c'est un long débat un long combat la
notion de sols structurel et vous en
êtes bien sûr vous en avez bien sûr les
la connaissance voilà c'était cela qui
m'intéressait aussi par dessus tout et
puis troisième point très important les
aspects de gouvernance gouvernance europ
et gouvernance nationale
c'est vrai que j'ai aussi beaucoup
oeuvrés et observer dans la sphère
européenne la réforme du pack de 2005 et
puis ensuite toutes les adjonctions
successives et je vais vous dire les
empilements de règles consécutives aux
différentes crises donc j'ai un regard
sur ce sujet là
et donc matière extrêmement riche métier
extrêmement prenant voilà qui m'a
passionné pendant pendant 20 ans et puis
ensuite parce que la vie passe je m'en
suis un peu éloignée
j'occupe aujourd'hui les fonctions de
directrice des risques de crédit mutuel
alliance fédéral donc j'observe les
risques financiers voilà depuis un autre
point de vue je pense que cette
expérience est également riche
d'enseignement et peu éclairer d'une
certaine façon les radio conseil
et surtout quand on pense aux événements
récents qui nous atteignent depuis 10
jours en matière de turbulences
financière donc ça ça m'a donné un autre
point de vue
peut-être une approche aussi des tests
de sensibilité je pense que ça c'est
extrêmement important aussi ne pas
s'intéresser qu'à la trajectoire mais
aux incertitudes qu'il l'environnent et
aux chocs qui peuvent la faire sortir
finalement de son rail
voilà et du coup vous avez on part un
moment donné mais je me suis dit en 2015
finalement toute cette expérience
accumulée savoir faire ou
que j'enseignais aussi par ailleurs j'ai
formé un certain nombre de mecs jeunes
collaborateurs je me suis dit finalement
est-ce qu'elle peut encore servir à
quelque chose et c'est à ce moment ce
moment là que j'ai eu la chance de
rejoindre le comité budgétaire européen
européen fils callboard en anglais qui
avait été créé en 2015 donc par la
Commission européenne qui était aussi un
conseil indépendant de la Commission
européenne
chargée de donner un avis sur la
politique budgétaire de la zone euro qui
était le chaînon manquant les budgets
chaque État conduit évidemment
souveraineté sa politique budgétaire
mais l'échelons d'articulation entre
tout ça était jusqu'à leur manquant donc
donner un avis sur la politique
budgétaire agrégée en langage technique
en gros est-ce qu'il faut est-ce qu'on
peut relancer il faut relancer ou est-ce
qu'il faut consolider les finances
publiques au niveau global
deuxièmement un avis de conformité sur
la façon la Commission européenne
contrôlait les budgets des États membres
et donc nous on avait c'était pas la
partie la plus facile du mandat est-ce
que la Commission européenne a bien
appliqué les règles communes et puis
troisièmement
on avait un rôle exploratoire aussi de
conseils auprès de la Commission
européenne pour
élaborer des propositions en matière de
réforme des règles budgétaires
européennes bon ça c'est un éternel
sujet et donc on avait fait un rapport
qui analysait la complexité des règles
et faisait un certain nombre de
propositions
conseils n'étaient pas les seuls
d'autres d'autres voix se sont exprimées
à ce moment-là et donc on voit un peu la
filiation avec le la réflexion
européenne actuelle donc je vais exercer
ce mandat pendant 3 ans jusqu'en 2019
voilà ce ben là était encore était
encore en arrière-plan dans mon esprit
donc
ce qui m'amène devant vous aujourd'hui
et pourquoi je souhaite rejoindre le
Haut Conseil des finances publiques
tout simplement
je dirais une motivation citoyenne être
utile
nous connaissons tous la situation des
finances publiques
aujourd'hui
après la crise du covid après avec les
incertitudes actuelles
ça ne va pas être simple
et il va falloir dans les années à venir
combiner je pense une double exigence
la soutenabilité des finances publiques
la maîtrise de la trajectoire de
l'endettement et puis la satisfaction
des besoins cruciaux
de notre société et où là je pense que
les finances publiques ont un rôle
essentiel à jouer en matière
d'investissement de transition
écologique de santé de service public de
sécurité de souveraineté donc
l'équation je pense n'a jamais été aussi
compliqué c'est vrai et donc moi je
souhaite à ma place avec mon bagage mes
convictions mettre cette expérience au
service du Haut Conseil et du Parlement
deuxièmement je pense que pour faire ça
il nous faut de la clarté de la
transparence
vous savez j'ai suivi depuis 20 ans le
long chemin
vers la transparence
l'exhaustivité je l'espère la qualité de
l'information transmise au Parlement
donc j'espère qu'elle s'est enrichie au
fil des années c'est un des gros des
grandes missions du ministère des
Finances que de mettre à disposition
l'information dans les parlementaires
ont besoin
et ça
je pense que ça s'est amélioré au fil du
temps mais que voilà il y a toujours
cette exigence et de ce point de vue il
me semble que la création du Haut
Conseil des finances publiques en 2012 a
été un pas extrêmement important
dont à l'époque nous n'avions pas
forcément mesuré le la portée je
m'explique cela a été une véritable
innovation que de faire intervenir
à une institution indépendante dans le
processus de prévision en amont de la
transmission du projet de loi de
finances ou du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale au
Parlement pourquoi mais parce que dans
ce dans ces jours qui précède la
transmission et je l'ai vécu il y a un
véritable échange il y a un
questionnement
il y a une exigence de cohérence sur les
chiffres sur la façon dont il
s'articule entre eux sur le réalisme et
sur finalement la question de savoir si
on va véritablement pouvoir atteindre
nos objectifs étant donné tout ce qui
est sur la table donc ça je l'ai
expérimenté je pense que c'est un
véritable enjeu et c'est au fond l'enjeu
démocratique de contrôle du Parlement
sur le budget et donc ça je voulais vous
dire que j'y suis extrêmement sensible
le Haut Conseil des finances publiques
de mon point de vue à trouver sa place
en tant qu'institution indépendante
c'est jamais facile pour une nouvelle
institution d'assoir sa crédibilité et
moi j'observe qu'au fil du temps
c'est avis rendus publics depuis le
commencement sont de plus en plus
relayés et que c'est une institution qui
a pu faire entendre sa voix
et pour terminer
question que je me suis posée c'est
qu'est-ce que moi je peux apporter au
sein de cette institution au delà de la
voilà de la technique de l'expérience
technique que je vous ai décrite moi je
crois que le rôle essentiel
d'un membre quand on est détenteur d'un
mandat c'est de se poser les questions
de poser les questions et de d'essayer
de tirer justement de tout cette
annoncellement technique ce qui fait
sens et donc je voulais vous dire ce
matin que vous pouvez compter sur moi
pour essayer de vous donner au travers
des avis dû au Conseil le maximum
d'éclairage pour
voilà pour que vous puissiez exercer
évidemment vos fonctions dans les
meilleures conditions et que en tout cas
j'essayerai d'y contribuer
voilà je vous remercie pour votre
attention je suis évidemment à votre
disposition
merci Madame Duchesne peut-être
Elisabeth Doisneau
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente madame cette audition nous
permet de connaître votre trajectoire et
nous permet aussi d'échanger ce matin
j'aurais trois questions
la première c'est est-ce que cette
vision que vous avez du fonctionnement
du Haut Conseil de des finances
publiques
est-ce qu'elle correspond à ce que vous
sentez déjà en soutenant ce matin votre
candidature et estimez-vous que le
processus de formation de sa vie doit
présenter un caractère collégial
ça c'est la première question ensuite
nous nous avons beaucoup regretté ici au
Sénat qu'on n'est pas de loi de
programmation et vous avez un petit peu
comment parler de ce sujet mais
j'aimerais avoir ta vie personnelle en
quoi ça pourrait apporter à notre
assemblée les éléments essentiels comme
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs j'ai retenu
ces mots de clarté de transparence et de
réalisme en réalité la troisième
question est-ce que même en l'absence de
loi de programmation les lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale
présente une dimension pluriannuelle et
je voudrais m'arrêter un petit peu sur
cette dimension là puisque il y a une
annexe obligatoire et et elle doit
donner donc cette trajectoire sur
plusieurs années et donc le Haut Conseil
ne pourrait-il pas s'appuyer sur les
prévisions de la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale par exemple pour
2023 afin de voir si la France ma îtrise
ses comptes sur ce périmètre jusqu'en
de plus même en l'absence de disposition
formelle en loi organique ne pensez-vous
pas que le Haut Conseil pourrait émettre
un avis sur la crédibilité de cette
trajectoire quadriennale en rendant son
avis sur le PLF et le PLFSS à l'automne
je voudrais en conclusion simplement
vous dire Madame combien j'ai retenu les
mots que vous avez utilisés pour décrire
votre enthousiasme en tout cas votre
motivation à remplir cette fonction ce
que je pense c'est que les finances
publiques tout de suite c'est un terme
qui fait peur alors
à la population et et voyez quand on
sort d'un texte comme celui de la
réforme des retraites alors que en fait
on est en place sur comment justement
quelle vision de l'avenir avec les
moyens que l'on a avec comme vous l'avez
dit aussi les incertitudes qui sont les
nôtres avec la dette qui est la nôtre
avec les enjeux d'investissement que
nous avons comment on peut expliquer à
la population tout simplement les enjeux
de de financement de notre vision
d'avenir moi je pense qu'il faut
absolument que on arrive les uns et les
autres à expliquer clairement simplement
quelles sont les conditions dans
lesquelles nous sommes et quels sont les
choix à faire et j'aimerais trouver avec
vous un chemin pas de vulgarisation
parce que je trouve ce terme un peu
galvaudé et un petit peu dommage mais
comment
pas forcément intellectualisé non plus
mais voyez trouver le chemin
d'explication où chacun est face à son
destin chacun face à ses responsabilités
merci Madame
merci madame le rapporteur général alors
juste le rapporteur général s'excuse il
n'avait une manifestation à 8h une
réunion avec le président du Sénat
notamment à 8h donc il pouvait être là
mais je vais peut-être poser une
question
un peu générale sur finalement
le regard que vous portez aujourd'hui
sur le cadre en vigueur tel qu'il
découle du pacte de stabilité de
croissance
cadre européen bien sûr et sur les
propositions qui sont faites de nouveaux
cadres qui prendrait je reste très
prudent parce qu'aujourd'hui on est sur
des principes mais qui prendraient
davantage en compte la situation propre
à chaque pays les investissements prévus
notamment en matière environnement et de
transition
et qui devrait donc donner plus
d'importance aussi aux trajectoires
définies par les États membres donc
comment vous vous voyez cette réflexion
qui se mène aujourd'hui entre les États
membres
au sein de l'ensemble européen
je vous laisse répondre peut-être
surtout aux questions de l'arabe
je commence par votre remarque finale
effectivement je pense que le les
finances publiques ou le budget sous
simplement c'est juste l'expression des
choix donc plus on est clair sur les
choix
plus on est audible dans le grand public
et je pense qu'il ne faut pas laisser
l'impression que tout serait dans tout
voilà il y a une responsabilité
budgétaire
c'est l'instrument les lois de
financement ce sont l'instrument majeur
principal l'exercice de la souveraineté
et de la et des choix politiques ne nous
cachons pas derrière les mots voilà donc
je pense que moi mon rôle ancien du
conseil c'est aussi de remettre les de
mettre les mots
et vous avez raison il faut que les
choix soient explicites et ne soient pas
caché derrière la technique la technique
c'est pour les techniciens
sur ma vision du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques
et la collégialité moi je pense que
c'est très important que dans un une
institution indépendante qui a à rendre
un avis il y est la recherche d'une
forme de collégialité
et le consensus le consensus pas
forcément mou
voilà et je pense que le consensus il
est d'autant plus riche qu'il y a eu des
débats et que les membres se sont mis
d'accord sur les termes du débat
donc il y a au sein de l'élaboration de
la vie
une étape très importante qui est
justement la rédaction de la vie une
fois les auditions passées et croyez
bien que j'y serai attentive et que j'y
participerai activement
sur la loi de programmation des finances
publiques que vous dire évidemment que
le
toute l'enchevêtrement
des textes entre les objectifs européens
et les lois de financement passent par
le vote d'une noix de programmation des
finances publiques ça a été un acquis
des années précédentes donc le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
votées aujourd'hui créer évidemment pas
juriste mais un vide juridique c'est à
dire que les avis
sont un peu bancales ce qui n'empêche
pas si j'ai lu les bien lu les derniers
avis le Haut Conseil de dire ce qu'il
peut dire dans ce cadre qui est inédit
donc je pense qu'il est très important
c'est pas de moi mais je pense qu'il
serait souhaitable que nouvelle loi de
programmation des finances publiques
puissent être discuté efface l'objet
d'un vote puisque finalement c'est quand
même l'échelon essentiel
et je suis pas sûr qu'on y prête tous
encore l'attention suffisante parce que
ce sont c'est une loi de programmation
cela formule des objectifs plus ou moins
volontariste mais c'est quand même
l'accroche nationale pour
atteindre les objectifs fixés dans des
discuter dans un cadre européen donc il
me semble qu'une des avantes avancées
aussi de la goût de notre gouvernance
nationale a été
d'accrocher aussi les lois de
financement annuels avec cette
trajectoire pluriannuelle
bon et une des sujets mais c'est la même
chose sur le sur le programme de
stabilité c'est vraiment aussi d'aller
chercher le la plausibilité et le
j'ose pas dire le détail mais là
l'information suffisante
ensuite je ne suis pas assez juriste
pour vous dire si le fait de donner un
avis sur la trajectoire de l'annexe du
PLFSS
serait suffisant je n'en suis pas si sûr
et en tout cas bon voilà il y a un
mandat du Haut Conseil il est là il a
été élargi
substantiellement puisque à l'origine
c'était quand même plutôt les prévisions
économiques et ne pas trop pas trop
rentrer sur les sur le reste aujourd'hui
c'est un mandat large sur la prévision
économique et financière sur les
dépenses sur les recettes sur la
compatibilité avec la trajectoire plus
réelle donc voilà mais le Conseil ne
peut pas s'auto saisir
de sujets qui à mon avis dépassent le
cadre de son mandat donc il regrette il
a regretté
et voilà
merci
traditionnellement comme nous avons deux
commissions
réunies
nous allons donner la parole
alternativement au membre de la
commission vous répondrez après un petit
peu c'est quand même à la fin mais vous
y reviendrez donc Jérôme Bacher
le président monsieur le président
j'ai trois types de questions récemment
à chaque fois le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques a remarqué le délai
très court pour donner un avis je vais
dire éclairer
peut-être consensuel mais en tout cas un
vrai avis
donc quel est votre sentiment sur le
sujet est-ce que ça pourrait vous amener
à dire finalement on ne met pas d'avis à
titre personnel enfin aussi du Haut
Conseil tellement les délais deviennent
trop bref pour examiner la crédibilité
et je peux être d'accord avec vous sur
le fait que la création du Haut Conseil
a permis de crédibiliser les hypothèses
macroéconomiques notamment depuis 2012
deuxième sujet ces lois de programmation
versus programme de stabilité vous
l'avez évoqué
est-ce que finalement on a besoin d'une
loi de programmation le programme de
stabilité peut-être respecté suffirait
c'est parce que si on respecte ni l'un
ni l'autre autant en avoir ni l'un ni
l'autre
troisième
question qui
[Musique]
je suis rapporteur des crédits sur la
dette
et aujourd'hui vous êtes bancaire
ça des risques un peu comme si moi je
t'ai responsable des risques pour la
Caisse des Dépôts aujourd'hui
le sujet d'être public d'être privé dans
le monde actuel est-ce que c'est pour
vous le sujet de la dette et elle la
menace principale sur nos finances
publiques ou est-ce que c'est peut-être
le consentement à l'impôt etc quelle est
votre avis sur la menace principale sur
nos finances publiques
monsieur le Président Madame comme vous
le savez dans le Sénat par
l'intermédiaire de la présidente
assassine d'Arnaud basée a fait une
excellent travail sur les cabinets
conseils après avoir auditionné
diverses personnes à ce domaine
donc la question que j'allais à vous
poser madame est-ce que pour vous par
rapport au Conseil des finances
publiques quelle est l'utilité de ces
cabinets conseils et aurait été recours
un jour ou l'autre à ses cabinets
conseils
merci Laurent Patrice Joly
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues madame
deux questions la première pensez-vous
que les chiffres les États-Unis
financières soient toujours neutres par
rapport aux idées aux idéologies aux
philosophies je vais vous donner un
exemple pour par rapport à mon propos la
logique d'organisation la société autour
des métropoles qui en fait à constitué
un peu le schéma de pensée des dernières
décennies avec conduit à sous-estimer la
place des territoires ruraux en France
et des modifications dans les modalités
calculs prenant mieux en compte la
réalité a fait que entre le 31 décembre
2000 et 2020 et le 1er janvier 2021 on
est passé de 18% de la population rurale
à 33% de la population rurale
tout ça pour dire que les chiffres
disent aussi ce qu'on a envie de dire
sur le plan financier dès lors que le
contexte est nouveau pensez-vous
qu'aujourd'hui le cadre
le cadre budgétaire européen est adapté
effectivement au défi qui sont devant
nous et en particulier aux
investissements que nous avons à
réaliser et donc il va falloir que l'on
dégage les capacités à investir et c'est
aussi une condition de durabilité
soudabilité de gestion budgétaire je
vous remercie
vous voulez bien répondre pardon
oui
merci monsieur le Président Madame moi
j'aurais voulu avoir le sentiment sur
les monnaies numériques
puisque ça on va on en parle on en
parlait et puis sur la sous-titabilité
effectivement donc d'être privé d'être
public et également un point sur sur
l'euro et sur également les différents
ciel de
tout entre les entre les monnaies au
sein de cette euro merci merci Sébastien
Moreau
je regarde je consulte pas de demande
supplémentaire madame Duchenne si vous
voulez bien répondre à ces quelques
questions
sur le délai de saisine du Haut conseil
c'est clairement un sujet et c'est
toujours un sujet
je n'ai pas connu
le conseil se satisfaire de son
d'avoir eu un temps suffisant d'examen
du des textes bon
de l'autre côté c'est compliqué le délai
de production je le connais donc je vois
bien dans quel jeu de contraintes tout
le monde travaille donc je ne crois pas
qu'une solution soit de ne pas rendre
d'avis je pense que c'est ce serait une
forme de
renoncement voilà je pense qu'il faut
faire pression sur
les ministères pour que le délai soit
suffisant et je pense que vous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
avez un rôle à jouer dans vos
commissions pour mettre la pression pour
que ce délai s'améliore et puis ensuite
il faut compter sur le sur
l'intelligence et la célérité du Haut
Conseil et sa compétence qui fait
toujours au mieux pour répondre dans les
délais impartis et avec un
une équipe support extrêmement
compétente et ça me permet de répondre à
la question sur les sur les cabinets de
conseils
je peux répondre très clairement je ne
vois pas l'intérêt
pour le Conseil
voilà il est doté de moyens il a la
possibilité d'auditionner des
personnalités
du monde économique
du monde social il a toute latitude pour
conduire ses travaux
donc je pense que c'est
c'est un sujet qui ne se pose pas
forcément
loi de programmation programme de
stabilité
oui il y a
alors dans le temps si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi il y avait les lois de
finances il y avait le programme de
stabilité qui arrivait en avril et qui
était suspendu
jamais raccordé à rien et on constatait
années après année
les objectifs des Calais
donc moi je crois à ça enfin
l'amélioration que constitue le fait
d'avoir un programme de stabilité une
loi de programmation qui s'accroche avec
des une correspondance entre les deux
objets qui ne sont pas de même statut
d'un côté il y a les engagements de la
France vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
européens et de l'autre il y a la
procédure budgétaire donc pour moi il
faut bien les deux et il faut que les
deux se parlent alors après il y a des
problèmes de décalage dans le temps
c'est très compliqué en pratique mais
sur le principe moi je voilà je pense
qu'il faut par renoncer sur ces sujets
là
sur la dette
la soutenabilité des finances publiques
c'est toujours un sujet qui est posé
qu'il faut regarder sans angoisse
excessive mais il faut le regarder on a
un endettement qui a beaucoup augmenté
on a un endettement des agents privés
également donc oui avec le contexte
actuel de remontée des taux d'intérêt
qui est quand même l'élément majeur de
l'année écoulée il y a des risques
sur les finances publiques on observe
déjà la remontée de la charge de la
dette donc il faut surveiller ça pour
éviter
un emballement on en est pas là vous
regardez ça avec
calme et sérénité et c'est d'autant plus
important d'avoir une vision claire de
ce que l'on veut faire à moyen terme et
le plus on sera ce que l'on veut faire à
moyen terme finalement voilà plus
lisible ce sera vis-à-vis de l'ensemble
des acteurs économiques et sociaux
est-ce que les chiffres sont neutres je
crois pas je crois pas moi vous savez
j'ai une culture de la statistique
publique
et je pense que c'est un fait essentiel
que la statistique publie alors c'est
pas le domaine du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques mais c'est un peu mon
bain aussi soit en capacité de répondre
à la demande sociale de fournitures
d'information
économique financière et social donc il
y a un dialogue qui est instauré avec la
société
civile et donc je pense que c'est un
enjeu aussi très important démocratique
sur le cadre budgétaire européen ça va
me permettre de répondre à votre
question sur le président bon
avec le recul
c'était simple au départ c'était simple
mais absolument pas adapté à la au
fluctuations économique ça c'est le cas
de 2000 de d'entrée de 1997
de bonne foi ce cadre a été enrichi
augmente voilà au prix d'un empilement
de règles successives au prix de
négociations aussi puisque on est dans
un domaine où nous négocions avec nos
partenaires et
je crois que tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire que le la le cadre est devenu
très très compliqué
voire inextricable et qu'il ne répond
plus à aux objectifs qui lui sont
assignés donc moi je regarde un peu ce
que sont les propositions de la
Commission je trouve qu'elles vont dans
le bon sens je trouve qu'il faut voilà
il faut faire de plus en plus simple
qu'il y a des règles qui étaient
inutiles un exemple le la trajectoire le
1/20 de réduction de la dette publique
qui figurait dans des textes de 2011 n'a
jamais été appliquée était complètement
en superposition avec d'autres éléments
d'autres textes donc il faut nettoyer le
cadre parce que c'est plus personne n'y
comprend rien même les spécialistes n'y
comprennent plus rien enfin je le dis
avec une grande tranquillité
et donc moi je trouve que ça va dans le
bon sens c'est à dire
on arrête d'appliquer le même cadre à
tout le monde on prend en compte la
situation propre à chaque État membre on
allonge un peu la durée l'horizon de
retour à l'équilibre on tient compte des
circonstances
on tient compte de la situation de
chaque État membre ça c'est un point on
regarde l'endettement à moyen terme et
de en pilotage on essaie de revenir à
l'essentiel et l'essentiel c'est la
dépense et les mesures de prélèvement
obligatoire et c'est tout
et ensuite il y a la dépense il y a les
charges d'intérêt qu'il faut regarder et
ce cadre autorise à un pilotage où on
fait entrer la dimension
d'investissement qui est quand même le
l'élément essentiel et ça on sait depuis
toujours que le bac de stabilité les
règles initiales
étaient biaisé parce qu'elle prenait en
compte la dépense courante ou le déficit
courant et que il y a eu beaucoup de
travaux académiques sur le sujet ou elle
il aurait peut-être fallu exclure les
investissements donc c'est un sujet
qui à mon avis revient d'actualité je ne
sais pas s'il faut changer les règles ou
s'il faut trouver des aménagements dans
les règles ça ce sera aux politiques
dans décidé mais pour moi ça va dans
vraiment dans le bon sens
et on en a besoin
donc il faut que le texte chemine
ensuite sur les données numériques
est-ce que ça change fondamentalement
la vision des finances publiques
je pense en tout cas que ça
ça permet une forme d'accès aussi
à de l'information et à de la
connaissance matière de finance publique
je pense que ça peut par certains côtés
l'accès à certaines données permet
d'améliorer la prévision économique et
financière ça a été le cap pendant la
crise covid je trouve que la les
conjoncturistes ont fait d'immenses
progrès donc oui il y a un apport
en termes de nouvelles technologies et
d'accès de traitements de la donnée sur
ces sujets là
sur la souteabilité je crois vers
répondu et sur l'euro moi d'amour je
dirais que il me semble qu'en ce moment
mais dans la éprouvé à d'autres moments
on mesure
l'apport que constitue le fait de vivre
dans une dans une zone monétaire
intégrée avec un euro voilà qui est un
euro de une monnaie de puissance sa
puissance donc voilà je pense que c'est
on est au cœur du du sujet et que en
tout cas il vaut mieux être dans en zone
euro que dans d'autres
dans d'autres juridictions aujourd'hui
merci Madame Duchêne madame la
Présidente est-ce que vous souhaitez
dire quelques mots de
merci
merci je voudrais vous remercier d'abord
mes chers collègues
d'être venu ce matin pour cette audition
sans vote donc
un peu particulier dans sa dans sa forme
pour rencontrer donc la candidate que je
propose donc au conseil vous dire
également que
Madame Duchêne de mon point de vue
de qualité si je puis dire l'une d'être
mais je crois qu'elle l'a dit
techniquement quelqu'un qui rentre dans
le sujet sans difficulté ces nombreux
postes précédents le montre et c'est
très important parce qu'on est au sein
d'une institution dans laquelle
évidemment il faut pouvoir se mouvoir
avec aisance
et que évidemment le
le temps passé à discuter n'est pas un
temps passé pour comment dire comprendre
ce qui se passe et ce qui se dit mais
bien pour euh
comment dire amener sa pierre à
l'édifice et et ces éléments et d'autre
part en Duchenne pour moi la qualité
d'avoir un parcours très varié et
notamment d'ailleurs son dernier son
poste actuel qui est un regard aussi
extérieur plus économique d'une certaine
façon sur les conséquences de tel ou
telle décision en matière de finance
publique et ça me paraît être quelque
chose de tout à fait de tout à fait
important enfin je vous signale madame
la Présidente mais vous l'avez compris
que évidemment si votre commission un
moment dans le cours de ces travaux
souhaités auditionner ou faire
participer à une audition un madame
Duchêne je pense qu'évidemment elle y
serait mais j'aurais pensé à sa place
elle y serait ou ouverte bien entendu de
la même façon que son prédécesseur avait
pu le faire avec je le dis beaucoup de
talents je ne lui ai pas de pression
exagérée mais mais tout de même nous
avions une habitude de travail régulière
et permettant de mieux décrypter un peu
les sujets je pense que pour nous tous
c'est une une opportunité quelque chose
d'important voilà merci beaucoup et
merci à vous tous